what
philosopher or philosophical idea had a
big impact on your life
not just in the space of cryptocurrency
but in general oh so we're
we're going now we're rolling going
right in because you majored philosophy
i did i majored in philosophy i didn't
know what to do
with my life and my parents said do
whatever you find interesting it's like
okay philosophy great
i find that interesting yeah um and it
had way more of an impact on my career
actually
then i thought it might you know
typically i guess if you do philosophy
go into a lot of finance so it sort of
makes sense but
um there are number of philosophers i
really admire
the big one of my favorites would be
descartes probably the notion of
skepticism it's sort of a rabbit hole
it's kind of hard to
pull yourself out of it basically the
brain and the vat theory
pulling yourself out of that but yeah i
really like epistemology
you know questioning what it is to have
knowledge
um so descartes was was one of my
gateways to that
do you think everything is noble like we
humans can
can know fully the objective reality oh
definitely not
no i mean i reality is very much
processed through your own
you know subjective lens so
how much do you think do we understand
about this world
because a lot of your ideas a lot of
things we might talk about today
are kind of trying to figure out human
civilization how
humans how human behavior works at scale
all those kinds of things that kind of
assumes that we have it
or we're able to somehow figure most of
it out
right so in your sort of when you step
way back
how much of it have we really figured
out well i think that's the conceit of
economics is
thinking that you can model human
behavior right in these unbelievably
complex systems
and then i think that's the modern
critique of economics like the sort of
tilapian critique
is that you can't have true knowledge
and they're much
less predictable than we think they are
and you know we behave
according to our accumulated assumptions
and we're using tiny sort of
data sets trained on the last 50 hundred
years
and they turn out to be horribly askew
and that's when we have our grey swans
and our black swans
uh so i'm i'm much more on the sort of
you know reality is much less noble than
we think side of things
you